[Música]
termino el ces el fuego decretado por el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin tanto
Moscú como kiev se acusaron de incumplir
La tregua que se dio con motivo de la
celebraciones de la Navidad ortodoxa
Irán anunció la ejecución de dos nuevas
personas vinculadas con las protestas
anti gubernamentales que iniciaron en
septiembre con lo que ya sube a 4 el
número de víctimas grupos de Derechos
Humanos denuncian que al menos 100
manifestantes se enfrentarían a la pena
de muerte
Gustavo Petro visita nuevamente
Venezuela el mandatario colombiano fue
recibido en Caracas por su homólogo
Nicolás Maduro Díaz después de la
reapertura total de los pasos
fronterizos comunes Tenemos reporte
desde la capital venezolana
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos con noticias de la
guerra en Ucrania porque terminó el alto
el fuego decretado por el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin con motivo de la
celebración de la tradicional Navidad
ortodoxa tanto kiev como Moscú se
acusaron mutuamente de no haber
respetado La tregua
Cristo nació en una cueva tuyo también
estamos en una cueva probablemente eso
tenga un significado especial
coloridas luces y altares improvisados
dentro de un resguardo subterráneo
cientos de ucranianos celebran la
tradicional Navidad ortodoxa en sótanos
por miedo a los bombardeos rusos
para nosotros está más o menos bien
cuando pienso en los chicos con los que
he hablado de kramators son Mis
parientes están en primera línea no
puedo imaginar lo que está pasando allí
al fuego decretado por el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin en las localidades
cercanas a la primera línea de combate
no vieron una tregua significativa en
kiev la capital cientos de fieles se
reunieron en torno a la icónica iglesia
ortodoxa de perchers labra la más
significativa del país donde se
emitieron en mensajes no sólo religiosos
sino también de aliento a las tropas
ucranianas
como nación buscamos vivir en paz
entendiendo a todos nuestros vecinos
pero el enemigo rompió la paz de manera
egoísta y traicionera e invadió nuestra
tierra derramando sangre sembrando la
muerte y queriendo destruir nuestro
estado y nuestra propia entidad
ucraniana
también los ucranianos refugiados en los
países vecinos festejaron la Navidad con
oraciones para poder volver a sus
hogares
solo podemos orar por la paz y la calma
y que finalmente tengamos la oportunidad
de regresar a casa tanto el Moscú como
en el cristianismo ortodoxo es la
religión dominante y se consideraba uno
de los lazos más fuertes entre ambos
países pero a raíz de la guerra que está
a punto de cumplir su primer año muchos
ucranianos le han dado la espalda a esta
festividad puesto que el patriarcado de
Moscú respalda la invasión del kremlin
el gobierno de Irán ejecutó a dos
hombres condenándolos a la horca ellos
fueron acusados de supuestamente haber
matado a un agente de la fuerza
paramilitar basic en las protestas
sociales con lo que asciende a cuatro el
número de personas ejecutadas tras las
movilizaciones
dos nuevos ejecuciones de manifestantes
en Irán acusados de matar a un miliciano
islámico se lleva a cabo la sentencia
judicial para la ejecución de dos
personas implicadas en el martirio de
seller a hamian el 3 de noviembre estas
dos personas junto con otros dos
alborotadores bloquearon la autopista y
perturbaron el tráfico sabotearon
propiedades públicas y cometieron
agresiones y lesiones contra agentes de
seguridad los ejecutados son Mohamed de
karami y Mohamed joseini Quienes fueron
detenidos el 5 de noviembre y condenados
a muerte el 5 de diciembre en un juicio
Express que duró sólo una semana según
amnistía internacional esta organización
ha reprobado las duras penas contra
karami y joseini y los otros condenados
como mohamedborogani Según el padre de
karami un ex karateca los no pudieron
elegir un abogado
amnistía internacional condena la
decisión del tribunal supremo de
confirmar la pena de muerte de Mohamed
borugani condenado en relación con las
protestas en Irán tras un juicio falso
las autoridades deben de tener de
inmediato cualquier plan para ejecutarlo
y anular su sentencia de muerte ya son
cuatro los manifestantes ejecutados
desde que comenzaron las protestas tras
la muerte de Max a mini una mujer que
murió luego de haber estado bajo la
custodia de la policía de la moral por
no llevar adecuadamente
elvislámico vamos a Estados Unidos la
actividad en el congreso ya puede
empezar después de que el republicano
finalmente lograra el apoyo de su propio
partido para ser presidente de la cámara
de representantes un retraso histórico
que ha ido acompañado de importantes
concesiones a la extrema derecha
por lo tanto el honorable Kevin mccarthy
del estado de California habiendo
recibido la mayoría de los votos
emitidos es debidamente elegido
presidente de la cámara de
representantes
representantes sí pero a qué costo
macarthy necesitó 15 votaciones para
reunir el apoyo de su propio partido no
pasaba esto desde antes de la guerra
civil de Estados Unidos sin embargo el
mismo lo ve como un asunto de
resiliencia
[Aplausos]
Puede que no les conozca a todos algunos
de ustedes son nuevos pero espero que
una cosa quede Clara después de esta
semana nunca me rindo
diferente lo ve el profesor de la
Universidad de Nueva York Emilio viano
en France 24 retrató un panorama
complicado para el nuevo presidente
está muy debilitado sufrió la
humillación de 14 rondas durante semanas
el alamas a la extrema derecha del
partido republicano ha estado
presionando para obtener concesiones por
lo que la presidencia no le ha salido
barata a macarce entre la concesiones
más importantes que ha hecho macarte a
los Rebeldes para ser elegido es que
cualquier diputado puede instar una
moción de censura para destituir al
presidente de la cámara lo que debilita
mucho su posición con esto el ala Ultra
conservadora del partido republicano
presionará para dificultar el acuerdo en
el techo de deuda con los así como para
iniciar investigaciones y comisiones que
marquen agenda lejos de las políticas
moderadas por lo que el reto final de
macarthy será luchar contra su propio
destino y evitar ser una marioneta
pasamos a Venezuela donde se llevó a
cabo una reunión imprevista entre el
presidente Nicolás maduro y su homólogo
colombiano Gustavo Petro es el segundo
encuentro entre ambos mandatarios que se
lleva a cabo en territorio venezolano
desde que Petro llegó al poder en agosto
del año pasado y tras reestablecer sus
relaciones diplomáticas desde Caracas
nuestra corresponsal Daniela Zambrano
con los detalles una reunión que duró
más de tres horas de manera privada en
el Palacio de Miraflores el presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro viajó Caracas
acompañado del canciller Álvaro Leiva
del embajador de Colombia en Estados
Unidos Luis Murillo y del ministro de
comercio en Caracas ya lo esperaba el
embajador de Colombia en Venezuela
Armando Benedetti por parte del gobierno
de maduro estuvo presente la primera
damacilia flores la vicepresidenta delsy
Rodríguez y el recién designado
canciller Iván Gil llama la atención que
esta reunión de última hora se produce a
pocos días del desencuentro entre el
grupo de la guerrilla del eln y el
gobierno de Colombia luego que Gustavo
Petro anunciara un cese al fuego que
tres días después fue desmentido por el
eln también una semana después de la
reapertura de paso fronterizo por el
puente de tienditas ahora denominado
atanasio girardot se espera que este
ocho de enero el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro viaje a Chile para
reunirse con su homólogo Gabriel en
medio de su segunda crisis tras asumir
el cargo el presidente chileno Gabriel
borics anunció la renuncia de su
ministra de Justicia Marcela Ríos su
dimisión se dio después de que partidos
de oposición protestaran por los
indultos otorgados en diciembre a 13
personas condenadas por el estallido
social de 2019 y por lo que amenazaron
con presentar una acusación
constitucional en contra de ríos en su
reemplazo estará Luis Cordero Vega
y en Colombia el carnaval de negros y
blancos reúne cada año a miles de
personas en la región andina de nariño
catalogado como patrimonio cultural
inmaterial de la humanidad por la UNESCO
el carnaval es una de las fiestas más
importantes de Colombia veamos un día de
negro otro de blanco en Colombia el
carnaval de negros y blancos es un
momento de mezcla cultural para celebrar
la liberación de los Esclavos así como
la unidad es una de las fiestas más
importantes del país ofrece un
espectáculo colorido el festival se
celebra cada mes de enero y atrae a
miles de personas a las calles de San
Juan de pasto en el sur de Colombia
salimos en familia y lo que hacemos Es
disfrutar
esto es una fiesta inclusiva
es reconociendo toda nuestra cultura y
nuestros ancestros bueno Nosotros
siempre estos carnavales los utilizamos
para divertirnos para iniciar un año
nuevo con alegría con entusiasmo con
mucha esperanza este Carnaval que
fusiona las tradiciones españolas
africana indígena de Colombia pretende
contribuir a romper las fronteras
raciales y ayudar a derribar Las
barreras culturales de ahí el nombre de
blanco y negro de los dos últimos días
del carnaval durante el primer día los
blancos se pintan la cara de negro para
celebrar la liberación de los Esclavos y
al día siguiente todos se visten y se
maquillan de blanco tolerancia y
respecto son los valores que quiere
transmitir esta fiesta declarada
patrimonio de la humanidad por la UNESCO
hasta que este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]